the moment  the government said we'll help colleges  out with your student loans  it became a business colleges and the  government teamed up together then  colleges had  no limitations on what they could charge  they said we're going to charge this  much no problem we'll lend it out we're  going to charge you no problem we'll let  them out and the government said hey you  can't write off your student loan you  have to pay for it but i can write off  all the other debt yeah so you and so  you were against slavery now you just  turned me into a slave what happened  there why are you doing that to me i  can't pay these payments oh but it's for  the good of your future because a degree  is going to change your life oh really  most people get a degree don't even work  a job that has to do anything with that  degree what the hell do you mean